Alain Jup est un jeune retraité à 57 ans
et après avoir cotisé 38 ans et 3 mois
il a fait valoir ses droits alors qu'on
prépare doucement les Français à
travailler plus longtemps pour sauver
notre système de retraite qui n'est pas
vraiment exemplaire et il n'aime pas
trop qu'on le lui rappelle comment vous
allez faire expliquer français qu' doit
faire des efforts alors que vous-même
vous avez pris votre tête très récemment
je vous remercie de cette question vous
avez pas de réponse demand
à il y a 2 ans en effet Laurent fabus
alors ministre de l'Économie et des
Finances avait pris sa retraite du
Conseil d'État à 55 ans à peine ainsi
privilège de la République Laurent fabus
comme Alain Jup peuvent cumuler leur
pension avec leurs indemnités d'élu
c'est une belle opération financière
mais impossible d'en savoir plus moi
j'ai simplement appliqué ce qui est la
loi
et j'avais fini ma carrière au Conseil
d'État j'avais droit à prendre c'est ce
que j'ai fait merci ça absolument rien à
voir
avec
arrêter circul rien à voir
maist pas les à jouun trait
DEC il dou 15 Ann
jiteor 1500 jusquà 6000 € par mois en
fonction du nombre
deandu un système pas très équitable
pour Philippe Deb la semaine dernière il
a donc déposé une proposition de loi
pour aligner le régime de retraite des
parlementaires sur celui des salariés du
privé pour lui c'est le préalable à
toutes les formes des
retraites actuellement il y a des
régimes spéciaux il y a la fonction
publique le secteur privé il y a des
régimes qui sont très différents les
Français sont inégaux devant la retraite
et donc ce que je pense moi c'est que
les parlementaires doivent donner
l'exemple devant tous les Français c'est
vrai que aucun des régimes de retraite
en France sera à l'abri d'une d'un
ajustement en fonction des réformes
générales c'estàdire que vous pensez que
vous devez montrer l'exemple vous n'avez
pas envie d'y toucher la réflexion est
en cours mais avec une majorité de
parlementaires farouchement hostile à
cette réforme pas sûr que les choses
bougent
vraiment